how significant is it that adidas
decided to cancel this partnership I
mean I think it's very significant I
think adidas is actually changing its
strategy when it comes to basketball
when adidas goes out and signed a deal
with the with an NBA it actually expects
the brand to become into more credible
more authentic to the audience that its
selling to and obviously in this case it
didn't work but why why didn't it work
if anymore because it probably didn't
have the right product if I didn't have
the right players it went after Derrick
Rose that was supposed to be the big you
know the next big hope right end up
being too you know too many injuries if
you look at Nike and what they've done
over the years they actually knew how to
get the right players that they have
LeBron when you have Kobe when you have
the Michael Jordan right basically you
run a whole product line around those
guys and you go out you create a lot of
buzz a lot of excitement around launches
and that's how you grab market share so
that's interesting so so Nike and so
Nike in particular you know they've gone
and made endorsements with LeBron James
and Kobe Bryant and others right and so
and so in fact I mean what what's
happened what's interesting is that then
LeBron James may have adidas endorsing
the league and the teams but then he
goes and turns around and endorses Nike
right so that's why adidas has really
lost this share right right and it's
it's specific to the pros where you can
endorse the entire league but then at
the same time you can you can turn
around and have an individual contract
with a player and yes adidas was the
formal the official partner of the NBA
but if you look at the numbers Nike has
more than 90% of the basketball shoe
market adidas was a distant second and
recently challenged by Under Armour they
stick in that spot so obviously
something was wrong and they had to
change something in the strategy so
could Nike or Under Armour come in and
replace that contract so obviously with
Adidas out of the picture we have Nike
and Under Armour kind of in the race
yeah we have to remember that the NBA is
a very international league you have a
lot of stars outside of you know from
different countries coming into the
league you have a lot of viewers outside
of the outside of the United States I
grew up in a different continent I
remember waking up in the middle of the
night just to watch Michael Jordan play
so Nike is a company with 60% of the
revenue outside of the US it's probably
you know fits nice
into that all global framework that the
NBA has Under Armour is a smaller
company is more focused on open areas
they're fierce they are and they're
growing very fast outside of the US but
I don't know if they're still in that
global as a global burning can can bring
the infrastructure for the NBA guys
bring up the stock chart of Adidas and
how its performed and just look at this
adidas the white line compared to Under
Armour Nike I mean those two guys are
pretty much neck and neck right now
but you know the CEO of Adidas has got
to be really in trouble here well you
know they already announced that I'm not
gonna prolong his contract is up with
2017 and they're gonna look for
replacement but they are gonna come at
the end of the month with some kind of a
plan to turn their business in the
United States and that's gonna be
interesting to see keys as you can see
in the stock chart right there they're
really an announcement what March 27th
that right okay they're gonna make some
sort of strategy and it works all right
so if you're an investor you want to
tune in to that okay thank you so much
for joining us Bloomberg intelligence
analyst ten grid